love this guy on a call with brian
anderson jeff franco calls uh braves
games which means he's uh very well
known in your household christopher
right he is they've been uh doing a
great job game five and chavez ravine
this evening and the braves can close
out the dodgers in a way that clearly
they could not last year ron darling
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you ron
hi rich great to be back with you what
are the braves doing so far that gives
you um a sense that we're not going to
see a repeat of last year that this is
essentially theirs to take
yeah i i mean last night's game when you
went into it and you thought that urease
is going to pitch against a bullpen game
of jesse chavez and drew smiley he
thought there was no way the dodgers
wouldn't win that game so it really i
think speaks to their toughness i think
it speaks to the trade they made for a
rejuvenated retooled outfield with
duvall and i know solaire's on the covet
list but of course rosario um
you know
that was always puzzling to me if you
follow baseball and when the minnesota
twins
uh didn't offer the qualifying offer to
eddie rosario like literally i know
everyone that follows the game was like
how could that happen like how could you
not offer a qualifying offer to a guy
that hits 30 and drives in over 100
who knows they can only answer that but
uh it's it's nice to see rosario having
a postseason that he's having so the
question i have for you ron is you know
we saw
urias in game two we saw scherzer close
out the giants and in that fifth game
and the the reasoning we're hearing
about them
it's been fine to use them in those
situations as opposed to just resting
them fully for starting is it was their
throw day
anyway and now we've subsequently heard
scherzer say his arm was dead and we
watched a 20-game winner in julio aureus
get cuffed around in a playoff game is
this
mismanagement or just unlucky
ron um
mismanagement and uh and and i usually
don't say things like that
um but
you know i i think around baseball
uh the intelligentsia
that run the game now believe like
believe that they have all the answers
and they have more answers than than
certainly the people
who ran teams when i played but
what you did in this postseason if
you're a dodger fan
and if you follow the dodgers is that
you pitched walker bueller on three days
rest he's never done that before
you closed with max scherzer in game
five against san francisco and you
started him in game one and then you
pitched a 25 year old left hander who's
had
shoulder
issues before
four times in 11 days
i don't know how you explain that any
other way um you know i i i'm sure they
will find the words and they will find
reasoning to be able to explain that
away
but for people who follow the game love
the game as i do
um
uh i think they'll come up short for me
anyway i mean that is not mincing any
words right there is it just the general
sense of okay this is the way it works
on paper and it should work regardless
because the numbers match up
honestly i mean we're talking about
smart people that would that would know
what you just said
um could lead to danger
especially since you've set it up
properly you got the arms the starters
that that is the envy of the rest of
major league baseball the dots yeah i
you know you know rich i i think that
once you get this close
um
it's really
difficult to not take your shot
with your best players right so you know
you have a roster of 26 guys there's
really only about 15 that you want to
play you know the rest of the guys you
will play but there's 15 pitchers and
and hitters that you really want want to
play because they're your best players
so what do you want to do in the
postseason you want to make sure
that your best players are on the field
for
the significant part of the innings of
those games i totally understand that
that's been done since the beginning of
time that's 100 percent
but you know at
some point
um you know you're talking about a ball
club that is one of the greatest ball
clubs of the last 10 years that is in a
position
in a game
five scenario
where they don't have
a person to start the game
um to me
that's um to me that's inexcusable i'm
sure that people will find uh you know
bullpen games and all those things that
have become a trend especially with
small market teams but to have the
mighty dodgers uh come into a game five
situation and not have a starting
pitcher of some renown now it's not all
their faults i mean clayton kershaw got
hurt um you know you had to go through
uh the legality issues of trevor bauer
who they signed um i get it
but um you know they retooled with sure
sir to replace kershaw
but they didn't retool one more person
to to present
and pitch and start a game five the
atlanta braves on the other hand lost
one of the top five players in the game
and they retooled them with rosario and
duvall and solaire
so you know that i think that's really
the storyline for me uh with the series
ron darling calling game five with brian
anderson jeff franco lauren shahadi on
tbs tonight joining me here prior to the
game in chavez ravine uh on the rich
eyes and show mercedes benz vans phone
line you've been around this uh sport
obviously and played in such high
leverage games uh where does eddie
rosario rank man i mean that is like
we're hearing names like robin yount
associated with him it's it talk about
not seeing that one coming how about you
yeah yeah well i like i said um i always
knew what an offensive player rosario
was i mean all you have to do is look at
his numbers and what he did in minnesota
i mean two seasons ago
he was 30 plus and 100 plus
the guy always offensively could do it
um maybe fiscally it wasn't the right
move for the minnesota twins to bring
him back um but i think the big story
rich for
for eddie rosario is that what gm and
alex and propolis is the president of
their baseball ops what gm trades for a
player that they know cannot help them
immediately
so they traded for rosario uh he gave a
bag of balls in a fungo form and he had
an abdominal strain and could not play
for them for a month
i don't know if anyone else trades for a
player that can't help you in the
immediacy especially after you lost to
acuna so he hedged his bet that at some
point rosario could help them and uh to
have two four hit games and i think he's
now 10 for 17 in this series is uh he's
been a difference maker well he caused a
traffic jam on the 101 last night i'll
tell you that
earlier than expected because i mean i
was watching with uh one of my sons ron
and we're like you know you guys set it
up perfectly about he's needs this for
the cycle he needs a double yeah yeah
and and i'm like this we could be
watching history like i've never seen
what's going on right here and and uh
and when he laced that ball to right i
thought this could be it we were like
saying hit the wall and then it went
over the wall and it was just as
shocking when it went over the wall my
god 12 total bases i mean i i
i don't know how to equate it and it
really is remarkable it really is you
know it's not it's only a remarkable but
think about what you just said i don't
think anyone in the in that's ever
watched the game
wanted a top spinned home run
to somehow stay and play because i was
the same as you i was like hit the top
of the wall bounce away from mookie and
give him a chance to have a double you
know at the very least like a hunter
renfrew let it bounce off his body and
go over the wall for a ground rule
there you go you know i mean whatever
whatever it took uh i got ron darling
here on the rich eisen show let's just
uh before i let you go cast our
attention on the
alcs and what you think is is working
for the astros now i mean that home run
that altuve hit in the eighth inning
similar to uh you know even though it
was a solo shot to tie the game similar
to the one that you saw in person with
clay cody ballinger pardon me uh in in
game four
um but unlike the dodgers the astros
have have just built off of that what
what are you seeing from houston that
that makes you think that they're
heading to the world series and also
maybe winning it what do you think well
one with altsuvi l2v sorry the physical
democracy
of baseball is one of my favorite things
you know you can be
uh you could be judge at six eight and
270 pounds and be one of the best
players of the game and you can be a
little fella like jose altuve and be
equally as good that to me is one of the
greatest things
about this game um as far as houston's
concerned the depth
of their lineup and i think a lot of
people are starting to see
that uh
jordan alvarez is is one of the best
hitters in the game from coast to coast
line to line uh what he can do and to
take those at bats against chris sale if
you look at the numbers left-handers
against chris sale they're
through the roof nobody gets a hit off
chris sale who's left-handed hitter and
for him to do uh what he's done and uh
and the astros um
despite um all the controversy of their
sign stealing and of their cheating i
mean there's no other way to put it
right um have always been an amazingly
talented team and it's a shame that they
ever had to do that because they didn't
need to do that that's how good they are
and and my final take rich on on the the
dodgers
and
and the atlanta braves yes atlanta has
to win tonight
because if they don't win tonight all
those things i said about pitching on
short rests and uh uh odius on four
times in 11 days all that stuff goes out
the window because they don't win
tonight they go to atlanta and they the
dodgers will pitch
serger and bueller on proper rest
that changes everything so um if they
don't win tonight
uh the dodgers have a beautiful peak
into coming back for the second time in
a row and they also have the uh oh not
again factor working in their favor
right
exactly a team that would get tight uh
thinking about oh no this is happening
again and atlanta certainly in their
history their great history of great um
great teams uh have had that more than
they they would like did you get that
democracy line from seinfeld because he
used that on us once the democracy of
talent and physique did he drop that
line on the booth uh uh broadcasting
he didn't but uh to even think that i
could use the same world uh same words
as the great seinfeld uh is is i'm
pretty lucky i'm telling you ron he said
that to us and i wrote it down and we
keep repeating it ever since he appeared
on the show three years ago he said
that's the beauty of baseball the
democracy of talent and physique now he
said that in saying that pitchers should
still bat then get rid of the designated
hitter okay so we almost came to blows
over that but
you know
my favorite science held is when he said
instead of raising the stamp two or
three cents raise it by a dollar and let
those guys get a long pants this
afternoon
i'm sure keith is still dining out being
on seinfeld i'm sure today
listen i i i don't even know what he
gets uh monthly a check from there but
uh my my beautiful friend turned 68
years old yesterday is that right
ron people don't know i don't think you
know yeah he he was one of the greatest
baseball players
ever i i i played with conseco
ricky henderson mark maguire
carney lancer daryl strawberry dwight
gooden i can go on and on yes keith
hernandez is the greatest baseball
player that i ever played no kidding i
mean because yeah because he could do it
all i mean the fielding as well for sure
yes building and he also had
he had a feel for the game that we all
aspire to but very few uh approach yeah
and gary carter too that's another name
that you could throw in that mix too i
mean at some point you know when people
talk about that 8016 well i always say
one thing we had the best right fielder
catcher first base when starting pitcher
and goodin and uh and kevin mitchell a
a future mvp uh couldn't make that
lineup that's right ron have a great
broadcast i look forward to hearing uh
you and uh the rest of the crew tonight
thanks for the call really appreciate it
thanks best to sue thank you you bet
there you go best of joanna there you go
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here